it's the holiday season and i hope that
you've all put up your decorations what
do you think
yay nay hanukkah christmas kwanzaa
as we always say christmas kwanzaa
hanukkah whatever you wanna call
um that's one of our writer's lines that
i really love and um
these guys that i'm about to bring on
are going to give you some inspo
whether you've decorated or not they're
the most amazing guys
their creations are on instagram and the
htv
handmade youtube channel please welcome
back to the show
andrew boza and dennis say to ducati
[Applause]
otherwise known as the crafty
lumberjacks oh look you have a kitty
yes this is our cat teddy krueger that's
right teddy krueger you spoke about
him the last time you were here well
that's funny because teddy krueger is
gonna play a part
in this holiday decor battle are you
guys ready
we're so ready all right all right your
challenge is to create some festive
holiday decor with whatever is in the
box we sent you you can create anything
a wreath
an ornament a holiday display display
and the stakes are high the winner gets
bragging rights
and the loser has to clean your guys's
teddy krueger's litter box for the rest
of 2020.
he's going down okay good that yeah
because i have two cats so i know how
bad that sucks
um all right let's open up your boxes
and see what you got i'm so happy to see
you guys
oh my gosh all right
all right what show me what you guys got
all right we got some yarn here some
branches
uh hoops uh bottle brushes crease paint
uh yes oh my gosh twine we have
oh sequins oh yeah
you got like your driftwood and your
like you know
drag show sequence i love it like
it's like rupaul's beach day um yes
we also tossed into random materials
that you each must use gold paper clips
and cotton balls because you know we
love to give you guys curveballs
all right we got him we got him all
right okay all right we're gonna check
in with you throughout the show and i'm
so excited i'm so glad you guys are back
are
you ready we're all right
on your mark get set create
hey let's check back in with the crafty
lumberjacks andrew dennis how's it going
it's going good you gave us all the
festive flourishes so we're definitely
feeling the christmas spirit yeah it
feels like santa's workshop up in here
minus the help from the elves and no one
wants to have to clean
teddy krueger's litter box let's face it
these are
good motivations yeah he's a big cat
oh my gosh i can't wait to see what you
make we're gonna check back in with you
i love you guys so much
let's check in with our crafty
lumberjacks andrew and dennis how's it
going
you know no glue gun burns so we're good
there we're just making a big mess
yes we're praying for a christmas
miracle at this point oh that's good my
daughter frankie
got her finger in the uh hanukkah candle
wax and then was like can i play with
your phone with the hanukkah candlelight
so
but glue gun that would take it to a
whole other level all right keep up the
good work we'll check back in
all right the crafty lumberjack you're
deep in holiday decor for our battle
let's see what you guys made
hi drew hi guys cute
oh my gosh i made a winter wreath
out of a hoop and i used the paper clips
to make chains and then i embellished it
with cotton balls for the snow
you can keep it up all january and
february yes and i made a yarn tassel
tree here i used my cotton balls to roll
little tiny snowballs
and then i embellish it with uh
paperclips for the star
all right then guess what you both win
we're sending you a self-cleaning litter
box and a casper cat bed
[Music]